Olivia Roden saying how do you or would
you respond to inedible food at a
restaurant okay I really like this now
Pat because you're vegan I'm guessing
you may have had more exchanges with
waitstaff about what it is that's been
served to you than I have in general
just because you may have the need to
confirm that certain items have not been
added to your dishes is that true well
that's the thing because sometimes an
item that isn't vegan has animal
products and it will just appear on your
plate even though it didn't say that in
the menu right so then you have to make
a big fuss about it sure it's it can be
kind of embarrassing honestly for you I
generally do not want to have those
conversations at restaurants number one
because people are generally working you
know they're working hard they're not
working for a lot of money generally I
think that they're doing the best job
they can however if something is really
really bad I will have to mention it
right so if there are a number of hairs
in the food that clearly don't belong to
anybody at the table that's something
I'm going to have to mention if it's
just a different item if a different
item shows up that I didn't order I'm
going to have to mention it there's only
one instance I can remember where I just
had to send something back or two
instances because it was just not cooked
the right way once I was at a restaurant
that pretended to be an Argentinean
restaurant and if there's anything I can
identify with accuracy
it's an Argentinean restaurant I showed
up the menu was not even remotely
Argentinean and I remember I ordered a
chicken breast and what came out was
basically a dry pock of chicken that
could barely even be cut with a steak
knife I mean this was the most
overcooked piece of chicken
I couldn't eat it I could not eat it and
I would normally try I really would and
I had to send it back and say you know
I'm sorry I hate to do this but I can't
eat this try cutting it I can't eat it
that was about ten years ago the one
other instance that I'm reminded of is I
was at a restaurant that's well known
for their seafood and I was served I
have no problem with sashimi and eating
raw fish when that's the idea but I
ordered fish that was supposed to be
cooked and it was essentially completely
raw and it was not one of the types of
fish that is traditionally served raw
and I had to say you know I'm sorry but
this has been served raw and every time
I do it I worry that someone in the
kitchen is going to spit on my food or
whatever so that's why really I
try to hesitate unless it's absolutely
necessary yeah it's a very interesting
angle that you brought up there too I
always make sure not to take it out on
the waitstaff right because they have a
very difficult job and I don't want to
be the one guy in a whole crowded
restaurant who's making a fuss about
something yeah so when I do do it it's
because of my dietary restrictions very
specific concerns but I really try not
to the one of the most uncomfortable
moments I recently had at a restaurant
was where a friend of a friend that was
with with us was just really treating
the waitress poorly and I hate that I
really don't appreciate that I don't
like it this person was just being very
rude for no reason whatsoever the
waitress was being very nice and really
treating everybody very well attentive
there were no incorrect orders and just
being rude to the waitress for no reason
that I could ascertain and I really that
that I find that hugely off-putting I
don't know about you oh absolutely yeah
I mean some people have this idea that
just because you're paying someone you
can you can treat them like garbage yeah
you wouldn't want your boss to treat you
like that at work you know it works ways
absolutely and I would I that instantly
is a major major to me that's a signal
that this is not somebody I particularly
want to associate with when they go out
and start treating waitstaff at
restaurants that they don't even know
like they are somehow beneath them or
worse or anything like that
real big it's a big red flag in terms of
someone's character when they do that
but so when I send food back it's pretty
rare and you know I find a lot of times
in in restaurants the people that I see
that I've been with that send food back
or complain about food it's almost
always because they're ordering things
that they don't really understand like I
remember someone ordered a oh I'm not
even going to say what it is because I
think it might be someone that watches
the show and might realize who I'm
talking about but they ordered a dish
that I knew they had never tried and
they seemed to misunderstand from the
description what it was and of course it
showed up and they didn't like it and
they were surprised at what it was and
they called the waitstaff over and they
were complaining but you know this was a
completely predictable and preventable
thing because of how you did not
completely understand what you were
ordering and I think that that's just a
major issue people need to figure out
what it is that they're ordering yeah
that one's on you you can't take that
out on other people
I totally all your fault absolutely
alright that does it for today david
pakman.com
slash membership that's where you sign
up for instant access to the bonus show
on all of the other great member
benefits and of course the coupon code
is I voted 17 and the fundraiser is on
major progressive media fundraiser at
david pakman.com slash donate don't miss
it